[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new marvel x-men video
we have amazing news
turns out marvel is taking new pitches
for x-men series on disney plus so i'll
explain what's going on what the details
are and what the timeline on this is
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of really big stuff coming up
and what will happen is is when they
start airing brand new episodes i'll
start doing more giveaways for disney
plus
subscriptions i'll just number these as
we go along just to stay
organized but if you didn't see the news
this past week it turns out marvel is
starting to develop pitches for new
x-men disney plus series already still
very early in the development phase
but one of the first ones that they're
apparently talking about behind the
scenes
super deep cut here is a revival of
x-men the animated series the producers
recently just did a big wizard world
virtual panel where they said they've
been having talks with marvel
about bringing the series back for new
episodes they just did the exact same
thing with star wars the clone wars
season 7
some of the best most polished crisp
looking animation you've ever
seen and story lines dave filoni is a
master of the craft
[Music]
they just did the same thing over at
warner brothers in the dc universe with
young
justice season three and now season 4
they're getting ready to make
so it's not a brand new concept
launching a brand new streaming service
and bringing back a lot of classic
titles re-matching them with new
episodes
they said this all started a couple
years ago and they knew that disney plus
was going to be a thing and they knew
that marvel would be getting the x-men
characters back from fox right after
avengers end game
they knew they'd be developing
live-action movies with new mcu versions
of the x-men characters
and new live-action tv series for disney
plus with x-men characters so it was
only a natural fit that they would do
more animated programming
kevin feige's already revealed his very
first animated marvel studios project
like
first big budget animated series that's
the marvel what if tv series that they
teased back at d23 with all that footage
but one of the earlier roadblocks that
they ran into is that this all started
when fox was still in the middle of
releasing
x-men dark phoenix which kind of slowed
down mcu
x-men things just a little bit mostly
just because of the backlash against
that movie was so big people were just
so
upset with the way they ended that
franchise after logan had been amazing
like you could do an amazing wolverine
movie
and the deadpool movies were doing so
well why can't you do good x-men movies
hardcore x-men fans will always love new
movies no matter what but there's just
so much fatigue with those
mainstream x-men characters and kevin
feige had already developed this full
marvel phase 4 slate of movies and tv
shows for disney plus
then way back at comic con feige implied
that they were just going to chill
on mainstream x-men characters even the
fantastic four
until they can find some banger stories
to do the way he talks about it during
this interview is that he just wants to
give them the debut that they deserve
in the mcu which just means that it's
going to take him a while to find the
right script
fantastic four what story are you gonna
tell that hasn't been told yet
uh all of that is spoilers but i'm
extremely excited
about those characters and about uh and
about bringing marvel's first family
um up sort of to the platform and the
level that they deserve
are you anywhere near casting no no
no story no no no see all the stuff we
did today
but you dropped all these teasers i just
said we didn't have time to talk about
it
so that's him mostly talking about the
live action stuff this is where all the
animated x-men stuff comes in
the animated series has always been
viewed as a wholly separate thing
completely different from the
live-action stuff
in the original series was cancelled at
the height of its popularity back in the
90s
had it not ended when it did it would
have continued for at least a couple
more seasons
it wasn't cancelled because it wasn't
getting good ratings or it wasn't making
money
it was super popular but it was airing
on the fox
network some of you may remember
watching it after school back in the 90s
it aired in the afternoons just like
some of fox's other classic 90s
animation
couple other minor series airing in that
same block of programming around the
same time on fox like spider-man the
animated series
batman the animated series then batman
beyond after that
and speaking of the 90s spider-man the
animated series the main actor from that
who voiced peter parker actually did
talk about coming back during the new
spider-verse movies he's totally ready
to come back
late last year and early this year
before the virus had brought everything
to a screeching halt
disney plus had actually debuted a bunch
of special new artwork and avatars for
x-men the animated series
so it just seemed like they were getting
ready to announce some new big projects
or do something special
with x-men the animated series right now
all the basic episodes are on disney
plus so you can watch them right now but
the series has never been remastered for
hd or
released on blu-ray or anything like
that so early timeline what they would
probably do is they would remaster
the original episodes first then green
light new episodes and then they bring
back all the original actors to just
pick up where they left off
because right now the producer said that
marvel's still trying to decide what
they want to do with the series
but all the original actors are ready to
come back and they would want to pick up
exactly where the series left off so if
you don't remember x-men the animated
series ended with season five
the final episode was basically landra
coming from the shiar empire to help
save professor x
magneto had almost secured mutant
supremacy
all over the world so he was getting
ready to achieve his ultimate goal but
professor x laid dying so leandra came
to basically try and preserve his
consciousness to transplant it to
another body to allow him to survive
but then they go off to the shia empire
leaving the x-men characters to just
wonder
if he would survive and that's the
ending it was a very emotional episode
so it was a great series finale even
though they hadn't originally planned it
to be the series finale
fox canceled the series before they
could plan season six so you were just
left to wonder what was going to happen
next
but had they gotten season six renewal
they would have just started with
professor x's consciousness being
transplanted
into another clone body by lelandra they
kind of did a version of this
if you remember during x-men the last
stand in the live-action movies
they kind of rebooted that continuity
the x-men timeline as deadpool says
is so confusing so they retconned some
of the elements of that film
but during the events of x-men the last
stand jean grey goes full
dark phoenix and kills professor x in
her childhood home and you spend the
rest of the movie
thinking that he's dead and gone but
then at the end of the movie there's a
post-credit scene where moira mctaggart
is standing near a comatose patient in
the hospital
and then freaks out when the person
speaks with professor x's voice
hello
it just implied that professor x had
transplanted his consciousness
into this new body allowing him to
survive so professor x
body jumping isn't a totally new concept
they kind of swept all that under the
rug when they got to x-men days of
future past but the idea is still there
professor x
is still powerful enough there are other
telepaths in the universe that are
powerful enough to transplant his
consciousness
into other bodies and even though i
don't expect him to come back patrick
stewart did say that he had meetings
with kevin feige and marvel about doing
new professor x
inside the mcu now that they gotten the
rights back but the way he talks about
it is very similar to the way that hugh
jackman talks about coming back as
wolverine
both of them were so happy with what
they did and what they accomplished with
the logan movie it was such a great
story
that they feel like it would be weird to
come back now
but that doesn't mean that he wouldn't
come back to do some voice over he's
just talking about
actually appearing as a live action
version of professor x on screen
so when we see brand new professor x
it'll probably be a recast or it'll be
james mcavoy coming back
i'm fully expecting most of them to be
recast
deadpool ryan reynolds is one of the few
immune characters
mostly what's happening right now with a
lot of that is that marvel is just
talking with all the other major actors
about whether or not they want to come
back at all so i think they're still
considering who they're going to recast
and who will survive the jump from the
fox marvel universe
although we've been talking about what
the story of deadpool 3 is going to be
i would love i would love to see them do
deadpool
kills the fox marvel universe it's just
a way to explain
what happens to all that continuity when
we pick up with x-men inside the mcu
as for what the story would be for brand
new episodes they could totally do
house of m they could do avengers versus
x-men that they were talking about doing
x-men
and avengers in the mcu in the
live-action movies and they could also
adapt
the whole dawn of x storyline that
they're doing in the x-men comics the
past couple of years which is sort of a
re-imagining of the x-men's backstory in
the marvel universe
let me know in the comments though they
do a revival of x-men the animated
series with brand new episodes
which big comic book stories do you want
them to adapt for that that they haven't
already done on the animated series
wait wait for everything click here for
that really funny deadpool wolverine
x-men reunion video that ryan reynolds
and hugh jackman did
and click here for that brand new marvel
shang chi movie teaser in iron man
easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you